2009 lebten erstmals weltweit mehr
menschen in den städten als auf dem land
bis zum jahr 2050 werden dass über 70
seien die städte der zukunft müssen sich
den problemen eines enormen wachstum
stellen wie die großstadt von übermorgen
aussieht erfahrt ihr jetzt bei pixum
watts an
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
what's on wenn man einige der führenden
experten des gebiets fragt was das
größte problem der zukünftigen städte
sein wird so sind sich fast alle einig
infrastruktur obwohl immer mehr menschen
von zu hause aus arbeiten sorgen die
wachsenden städte für immer mehr verkehr
die lösung dafür könnte die smart city
sein die smart city überwacht mit
kameras und geschwindigkeitssensoren die
autos der gesamten stadt regelt in
echtzeit den verkehr über ampelphasen
und leitet autofahrer per smartphone
direkt zum nächsten freien parkplatz
weniger lärm bessere luftqualität und
mehr platz für fußgänger und
fahrradfahrer in der innenstadt das sind
oft geforderte ziele und deswegen
überlegen manche städte jetzt schon
bereits nur noch elektroautos in den
innenstadtbereich zu lassen
die energieversorgung ist ein weiteres
großes problem von städten
diese verbrauchen nämlich jetzt schon
drei viertel der weltweiten energie und
stoßen 80 prozent aller emittierten
treibhausgase aus viele projekte widmen
sich deswegen der grünen statt
so soll zum beispiel das beton mehr
verschwinden heutzutage halten
häuserfronten höchstens das wetter
draußen aber in zukunft sollen sie bei
der energiegewinnung helfen ein projekt
aus hamburg hat bereits jetzt eine
glasfront im einsatz in der algen das
sonnenlicht genießen und dadurch wachsen
können sobald die eigene dann
abgestorben sind kann man aus der grünen
masse energie und wärme gewinnen und
auch generell sollen städte viel grüner
werden
park steigern die lebensqualität der
bewohner und regulieren die temperatur
in der stadt
in london wird zum beispiel gerade
darüber nachgedacht eine garten bridge
zu bauen die den bewohnern einen ort der
erholung bietet vielleicht das neue
wahrzeichen von london
und genau wie die brücke werden in
zukunft immer mehr und mehr grünflächen
entstehen
ob als parks oder auf den dächern der
häuser und sogar in den häusern wird es
grüner sky funding soll die
landwirtschaft in die stadt holen um
transportwege zu verkürzen
in hochhäusern wachsenden etage für
etage agrar produkte wie tomaten und
kartoffeln um die stadt zu ernähren led
beleuchtung und temperatur kontrollierte
räume sorgen für ein optimales
pflanzenwachstum
anstelle von schwerer erde unter der die
hochhäuser vielleicht nachgeben könnten
wird ein wasser system verwendet das den
pflanzen die nötigen mineralien und
nährstoffe liefert auch wenn solche
farming zauber heute noch nicht wirklich
wirtschaftlich sinnvoll sind
so ist das absehbar dass die steigende
weltbevölkerung in zukunft definitiv
mehr nahrung benötigt ein mega
spannendes konzept der zukünftigen stadt
kommt von andy sein team aus amerika
times square 3015 zeigt uns wie der
berühmten times square in 1000 jahren
aussehen könnte nämlich wie ein
gigantischer wolkenkratzer mit über 1700
metern höhe bietet dieser turm platz für
12.000 menschen also kleinstadt quasi
schon drei einkaufscenter eine skihalle
einen strand eine ganz universität und
ein ganzes football-stadion mann david
man glaube ich nicht mehr nach draußen
und als wäre das noch nicht genug haben
sich die designer überlegt den heutigen
times wer ganz nach oben in 17
kilometern höhe in eine glaskuppel zu
setzen
nichts für leute mit höhenangst aber so
eine smart city bietet nicht nur
vorteile wie wir aus dem spiel hot
stocks wissen kann es sehr gefährlich
seien alle informationen einer stadt
zentral zu lagern und zu verwalten
denn sobald diese informationen in die
falschen hände geraten und derjenige
alle ampeln überwachungskameras und
u-bahn in der stadt kontrolliert ist das
chaos vorprogrammiert
ich bin extrem gespannt was die zukunft
mit der typischen großstadt macht was
denkt ihr
welche projekte findet ihr am besten
schreibst du auf jeden fall unten in die
kommentare ich bin sehr auf eure meinung
gespannt und meine heutige hörbuch
empfehlung level im jahr 2049 wird ein
architekt beauftragt eine riesige
untergrund anlage zu entwerfen
in der die menschheit zuflucht finden
soll mit dem ersten link in der video
beschreibung könnt ihr euch das hörbuch
gratis sichern und uns ein wenig
unterstützen
hier findet ihr noch meine beiden
letzten videos von watson und ich sage
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal